[Musique]
pour
au sud de l'océan indien l'île de
madagascar que l'on surnomme aussi l'île
rouge avec ses 15 millions d'habitants
dans la gascard est un des pays parmi
les plus pauvres du monde
pourtant lille à de nombreuses
ressources
elle possède un réel potentiel minier
agricole mara est aussi touristique
un contraste sur lequel je m'interroge
pourquoi malgré ce potentiel madagascar
semble incapable à se développer pour
essayer de comprendre
j'ai choisi morombe une petite ville de
la côte ouest que je connais bien je me
suis rendu au mois de juin 2001 quelques
jours avant une éclipse totale de soleil
solo le maire de morombe me parle de cet
événement comme une réelle opportunité
pour développer le tourisme
cette éclipse est pour moi l'occasion de
faire un état des lieux de la vie aux
côtés de solo je vais découvrir les
enjeux du développement qu'est ce que
j'ai fait c'est quand même de travailler
un petit peu aux rôles mais nous on est
avec vous et si vous feriez au bureau
[Musique]
morombe est une sous-préfecture de 8000
habitants elle fait partie de la
province autonome de tuléar solo et
maire de cette ville depuis 1999 solo
connaît bien le potentiel de sa ville
mais il est confronté à deux problèmes
d'un côté son budget annuel qui n'est
que de 500 millions de francs malgache
soit 435 milles francs français de
l'autre le fait de ne pas appartenir
l'arema le parti politique au pouvoir
largement dominant dans tout madagascar
[Musique]
depuis son arrivée à la mairie entouré
de sa petite équipe de conseillers ce
lot se bat pour développer morombe un
projet un peu fou car elle doit trouver
les fonds nécessaires pour y arriver et
doit en plus pour vaincre chacun dans la
population de son utilité construire un
nouveau collège réhabiliter la route
pour désenclaver la ville préserver la
production agricole locale attirer les
touristes tout simplement assainir et
nettoyer la plage rien d'évident surtout
quand il ya si peu d'argent
qu'est ce qu'elle vient de faire une
consultation parce que c'est un très
beau médecin lorsque j'ai rencontré ce
lot il ya un an
il m'a convaincue que morand b était le
meilleur endroit de madagascar pour
observer l'éclipsé en effet meuron b
al'avantage d'être la seule ville de la
côte d'où l'on pourra observer l'éclipsé
au dessus de la mer d'ailleurs à
l'époque on envisageait déjà 3000
visiteurs amoureux b alors que la ville
dans la guerre clou d'une centaine par
an dans ses espoirs les plus légitimes
solo à espérer un soutien du
gouvernement de 260 mille francs
français pour restaurer la rue
principale mais à ce jour rien pas un
centime à mambé en fait le gouvernement
a attribués tout son budget et clips
sarah nuire un site touristique où
certains notables bien placées ont des
intérêts
finalement ce lot a dû se contenter de
26 mille francs français prélevé de son
propre budget dont profite ce qu'on fait
le gouvernement n'a rien d'un amour mais
le gouvernement n'a rien terreau unis
sauf dans le secteur aviation où on a
réhabilité la piste de l'aéroport
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
habituellement le héros dôme accueille
deux avions par semaine mais sur la
période de l'éclipsé est une rotation
d'une quarantaine d'avions qui vont
débarquer les visiteurs attendus parmi
eux le maire attend le gouverneur de la
province qui profitent de l'éclipsé pour
revenir sur sa terre natale
après avoir passé une cravate et troquer
sa vieille 504 contre un 4 4
le maire arrive à l'aérodrome pour jouer
les ambassadeurs
je souhaite
mais sur sa vie et dans le pays aaa avec
un beau temps oui oui c'est bien tu as
tu bien y'a très roulant et je pense
qu'on a pris oui bien sûr ailleurs plus
que voilà un grand honneur pour la vie
puisqu'il est originaire d'ici
[Musique]
trois mille touristes attendus en les
regardant débarquer j'étais heureux mais
aussi inquiet pour solo car je savais
que les hôtels et auberges de la ville
ne disposait que d'une centaine de lits
[Musique]
jean de dieu maharante a été
nouvellement élu gouverneur de la
province
contrairement au maire de morombe il est
affilié au parti arema
[Applaudissements]
après
m
ap
[Applaudissements]
m
c
[Applaudissements]
ap
agréé
[Applaudissements]
un peu taré
le gouverneur a à peine débarqué le
maire retrouve sa 504 avec laquelle il
part régler les derniers préparatifs
le ballast non non non
[Musique]
c'était m
narcisse est adjoint du maire et
responsable des services de l'équipement
de la ville il est lui aussi sur le
terrain pour préparer l'arrivée des
visiteurs
aujourd'hui il a pour mission de faire
nettoyer la plage par les détenus de la
prison de morombe mais il ya un petit
problème
la couronne demande va nettoyer la plage
d'argent d'amélie la porte léveillé pour
les gens qui vont camper sur la place
si sa plage value qui contient
monte hellman la peine de riot uma états
et soyaux mal à perdre en place à alain
publiés
noyer alors que quoi vous allez
retrouver ou les peines pour les peines
je vais essayer je peux faire
là y'a pas s'il n'y a que trois je vais
demander aux gens
si ça non
jusqu'ici la plage n'était qu'un lieu
d'habitation pour les pêcheurs mais
l'arrivée des touristes est l'occasion
de s'occuper de sa propreté
à commencer par la construction de
toilettes publiques
c'est vous qui allez panne à la radio il
faut pas avoir peur de l éclipse
ce n'est pas un phénomène dangereux
c'est un phénomène naturel qui n'est pas
dangereux si vous êtes dehors si des
animaux sont dehors
il n'y a aucun danger vient vraiment
aucun danger le seul danger qui est réel
c'est de regarder le sommeil sans
lunettes c'est le seul danger c'est pas
la peine de s'enfermer dans des maisons
de se cacher sous les lits c'est de
rester dehors
la solution du problème c'est si on veut
regarder sommaire mais j'arrive sur un
ticket par des artistes populaires à
wana à votre jeune âge
alexis miss miss you know what i
canadien
le comité national pour les clips
annoncé la venue d'au moins quarante
mille touristes mais voilà depuis
certains ont entendu parler du choléra
mais surtout tôt la faible capacité
hôtelière de madagascar au plus
l'annoncé d'une arrivée massive
d'étrangers a entraîné une envolée des
prix surtout dans les zones d'ordinaire
tous fréquenté par les touristes voulant
là on vient depuis hier avant on était à
un haka savoir pas trop stressés on est
un peu stressé puisqu'il ya quand même
des responsables étaient aussi bien sûr
de la population des questions des
visiteurs et aussi le la gestion de
visite officielle de temps qu'il ya de
quoi stresser mais je pense que c'est
peu modérée puisque ça bien passé et
vous pensez tout le monde a réussi à
manger là je peux pas le dire puisque il
ya quand même une surprise c'est vain de
demander ou à tout le reste on
maintenant mais il un petite surprise
pour tous les restaurateurs qu'on n'a
pas attendu aussi de visiteurs
qu'ont prévu donc je pense que quelqu'un
mange des sandwichs et tout ça
l'hôtellerie c'est les campinois qui
prime
j'ai écouté les récits on parle du coup
leur a enlevé ce qui n'est pas vrai si
ce loup prend cette annonce contre lui
c'est sans doute parce qu aucune
publicité n'a été faite sur morombe il
est difficile d'organiser son arrivée à
mauron b car la ville est loin d'être
connecté avec le reste du monde même
s'il ya un téléphone public par
satellite
il est plus qu'aléatoire soit n'y a pas
de carte pour téléphoner soit l'antenne
est mal orienté et on ne capte plus le
satellite le moyen le plus sûr pour
communiquer avec l'extérieur reste la
radio qu'on appelle le bel
[Applaudissements]
tu viens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
josh homme et john lannan dit amusé à
[Musique]
quoi vous attendre à gap et dans tout le
jardin tv bonjour la grande ère en sa
compagnie américaine me réjouit david
cameron
zagbayou
[Musique]
anne a bondi que banale dont beaucoup
les amis le bâtiment et ont l'occasion a
nommé m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'armée du mahdi
le temps du déni buenos aires
[Musique]
à
c'est tout bon
un sourire
comment
pour fêter la venue du gouverneur à
morro bay les représentants locaux du
parti arema ont organisé un bal le maire
et sa femme et ont fait une brève
apparition brève car on a tout
simplement oublié de leur réserver une
table
[Musique]
il inclut
finalement des trois mille visiteurs
attendus seulement 700 ont choisi de
venir à morumbi qu'ils soient
scientifiques chasseurs d'éclipsé
curieux aux touristes étrangers aux
malgaches venues par avion ou par la
route
ils ont vite rempli les trois principaux
hôtels de la ville et se sont tous
retrouvés sur la plage
est ce
m
et humidifié
[Musique]
ah ouais
à mannheim allemagne à l'aller on est à
vienne m à sortir madagascar de la zai
magnifique comme la claque est initié
par la cnac
ces dons car à nuire sur le site
officiel que la majorité des visiteurs
se sont rendus
pourquoi tout est dit villers à la nuit
justement là-dessus nous on appris que
ghannouchi s'est pas très bien passé lee
mais des nuages enfin que à part moi
madagascar c'est mon mail avec endroit
pour regarder les clips vous êtes ça
vous êtes contents vous êtes vous fait
quoi non j'ai pas content ou pas contre
temps mais ça c'est le caprices du temps
mais tout le monde les météos et tout le
monde le connaît comme en tout cas ça
vous donne envie de revoir des touristes
un bon beh oui ça m'a donné envie à ce
que j'ai demandé quelqu'un ne connaît
pas que c'est le maire qui parle puisque
je suis fait un petit chant basque en
passant je ne dis pas du mal d'une bombe
dans la majorité des cas à moi je
tomberais naissance est de tomber dans
des 110
[Applaudissements]
si les clips ça rapportait beaucoup
d'argent aux quelques hôtels de la ville
la plupart des habitants le maire et la
commune n'ont pas gagné grand chose
sinon l'envi de revoir des touristes
amoureux mme b en tant que touriste
qu'est ce qui peut faire mais on a ainsi
pu impeccable là mais le problème en
corse et les pistes donc si les
solutions là même les touristes au
maximum ce qui devrait être moins trois
heures
sinon c'est fatigant mais maintenant
refait semaine suffit pas sans ratés à
val d'or
les passants dans la polémique et pour
les cdd voire la biodiversité dans
l'euphorie piqué puis le l'accueil août
oui les résidents des oiseaux et le long
des débats ou pas dans batman un peu de
sources thermales la côte est et voulait
venir en mai prendre l'avion si on
arrive à faire 103,4 souci sera
impeccable et vous pouvez faire quelque
chose pour ce bon pour améliorer sa
green gym et opérateurs accepté bien dû
s'y regrouper dans un intérêt commun
je vais essayer de le faire
en effet la piste est un problème car
venir ici est une vraie expédition
il faut 12 heures si tout va bien pour
parcourir les 280 kilomètres qui
séparent morombe de tuléar
d'ailleurs ces pistes fait l'objet de
multiples débats elle est souvent
l'enjeu de campagne politique comme si
elle était la solution à tous les
problèmes
le maire m'emmène sur cette piste car il
veut aussi montrer la vallée du fleuve
en boucle dont on dit ici quel est le
grenier du sud de madagascar lors de sa
venue à tuléar
le président de la république a déclaré
qu'il attribuait 12 milliards de francs
malgache soit 10 millions de francs
français pour la piste tue les arbres ou
b c'est ce qui va être fait avec 12
milliards pour la piste réhabilitation
12h15
la classe des points d'accord
tous les trous qui allait accoucher ou
pas oui oui ça fait partie du
je suis allé voir le gouverneur et les
sénateurs pour leur demander ce qu'ils
pensent de ces 12 milliards attribués
par le président de la république
salade de route nationale que de nom
d'une route nationale mais effectivement
c'est une piste au coût actuel de
l'habitude mais que le manioc riz lait m
ça fait au moins 250 milliards c'est
quand même parce que c'est le budget
votre seulement ça vaut 1 km 1 1
milliard de kilomètres notre manière
mais on n'ira pas jusque faut pas être
rêveur on n'aura jamais cet argent là
mais c'est que ces corps essaie de faire
d'abord soigner les ouvrages d'art soyez
voir les points noirs qui empêche
les véhicules de circuler tout au long
de l'année
pour une route bitumée peut-être qu'on
finira l'année
ici
cinquante trois années sans avoir une
route bitumée au moins une piste il ya
trois bien lisse c'est possible quand
même oui il ya le problème climatique
aussi tous les ans il ya des inondations
ici
ça me prendrait donc il ya une réflexion
déroule tous les ans et tous les ans
aussi à une forte détérioration des 60
le maire se préoccupe de cette piste car
elle est le cordon ombilical de morombe
et son état est une sorte de régulateur
pour le développement économique de la
ville
le fleuve mangou qui détruit la piste
chaque année certes mais ce fleuve et
ses riches alluvions sont aussi à
l'origine de cette vallée très fertile
de plus de 120 mille hectares en 1962
l'état malgache investi plusieurs
milliards
il a aménagé des dizaines de kilomètres
de canaux est planté 13 mille hectares
de rizières et de culture des haricots
de qualité appelé le poids du cap
le poids du cap produits uniques dont
l'angleterre était le principal
consommateur a fait la réputation de sa
mangue ou qu au fil des années les
cultures se sont dégradées par manque
d'entretien des digues et manque de
formation des exploitants
la qualité du poids du cap a baissé sa
production s'est réduite progressivement
pire encore la digue principale qui
protège la piste et réguler l'entrée des
eaux du fleuve dans les cultures menace
de s'écrouler à la prochaine saison des
pluies
devant cette situation d'urgence l'état
malgache a décidé l'octroi de 143
milliards de francs malgache soit 124
millions de francs français arriveront
ils à temps et a une éthique il ya quand
même
en tout cas de 400 mètres de digue donc
si on n'arrive pas réhabilitation
habilité se dit que la fin de la pluie
cette année si c'est fini lui permettra
va être coupée en deux parce que ça
devienne le lit de mon gouvernement je
pense
s'il veut pas on va le pousser pour le
faire d'ailleurs il a déjà dit qu'il va
le faire
vous savez que nous aurons bel aspect de
mourir gorge de rivières des milliers et
des milliers d'hectares et là aussi on
remercie le pouvoir central d'avoir pu
trouver des financements qu'ils ont même
pas encore suffisant mais qui sont déjà
las pour le démarrage il ya cent et
quelques ya 143 milliards pour la somme
a book ne pour le
réaménagement de de 5000 hectares de riz
je suis allé voir monsieur balbigny un
important opérateur économique de la
province
installé à morumbi il achète le poids du
cap produit dans la vallée du manque
book pour les exporter à défaut de
l'angleterre vers les îles de la réunion
et de maurice
tout et tout et en urgence est ce que
comme je vous dis à onze mille hectares
et qu'il n'y a que quatre mines ou 3000
qui sont exploiteurs des encore ces
trois ou quatre mille hectares exploités
risquerait de partir si ce barrage ne
sera pas peur mais je crois que ça fait
déjà deux ou trois fois j'ai entendu à
la télé à la radio que le président
europe icade a bien prononcé qui à 147
milliards ou le bambou budget 100
milliards là peut-être je vais peut-être
cette fois-ci ça va venir parce que
cette fois ci ça va vraiment bien venir
il ya 5 6 ans avant peut-être ça venait
pas mais là je crois que ça viendra
parce que le monsieur du hac celle où il
est je ne sais pas moi je crois qu'il y
met le papier personnellement le
président de la région
[Musique]
comme la qualité donc a été détruite
depuis 1981
jusque là la machine pointe du cap à
londres et l'est des côtes et maintenant
elle est condamnée parce que il le faut
20 25 mille tonnes l'année dernière dans
les talibés à 9 8 mois donc j'avais
réfléchi c'est plus la peine c'est pas
c'est plus la peine de venir un mauvais
vous savez que qui se produit que j'ai
transféré ici qui aurait dû être déjà de
l'autre côté mais j'étais obligé parce
que la route était coupée entre bakil
tullia pendant la saison avait mauvaise
saison j'étais obligé de les ramener ici
c'est des magasins que louis je suis
j'étais obligé même d'acheter la somaco
dit cela il ya même pas de moi j'ai un
copeau 8 milliards de la banque et les
intérêts courent toujours
comment voulez vous que je puisse opérer
dans des conditions cadres dirigeants
nous ont pratiquement lonza un probléme
est trop grand ou le mandat sanitaire ou
dépitées malabo s'ils profitent ou le
gavage gouvernement des entailles twayab
hamza baghouli tri postal des abonnés
députés en commission développe marinade
ce post crise et sénateurs bouquet
sternal postale est ami avec notamment
présente elle interrompt ni problème dit
il et fille souffre en plus tard pour
tickets pour des litiges
ne changez pas pour le team les collets
condamnant team scanning contre 200
paysans français examinent les avez une
carte identique à bail arrivait nombreux
amis qui tient si marie farina
[Musique]
l'essentiel de la population de morombe
constitué de pêcheurs de l'ethnie vaise
ici le salaire moyen est de 110 francs
par mois un salaire dérisoire alors que
la mer est extrêmement riche en poissons
crevettes grave et langouste ses
richesses pourraient être vendus dans
tout le pays et même à l'exportation
mais à morumbi les produits de la pêche
peuvent difficilement quitter le marché
local le mauvais état de la piste et
l'absence de camions frigorifiques
bloquent littéralement tout espoir d'un
développement économique
[Musique]
le littoral est le territoire des
pêcheurs et ceux traditionnellement
depuis toujours sur la question du
développement du tourisme à morombe le
maire est confronté à ce problème de
territoire car les pêcheurs habite
directement sur la plage il ya un petit
problème puisque d'habitude il ne
voulait pas y avoir des constructions
sur la place mais le fait est là tant
que ce que je pourrais faire en tant que
maire c'est de déclasser d'essayer de
normaliser les habitants et tout ça que
les de la piscine tout encaisser 2
garder quand même s'il reste puisqu'il y
avait une explosion sociale dation leurs
élèves et protéger tout ce qui est des
pâtis sel dans le corps les arguments ce
que vous avez et notre économie dépend
de ça et s'il ya une habitation ici on
ne profite pas le le potentiel que notre
ville un temps que la commune est prêt à
vous transférez ici avec un terrain
gratuit
nous avons un problème voilà une
tradition
il ya une loi pour une voie toute
récente qui dit que les terrains
domaniaux appartiennent à la commune
tant que c'est la commune qui n'est pas
loin doit publier ses terres et là il ya
une confusion parce que par exemple
reculé à le service des domaines
sans me consulter distribuer
terrain comme ça allait ce qui fait que
finalement
que nous savons pas exactement ce qu'on
doit faire et est un problème qui a dit
hier au gouverneur ou l'amérique non pas
le gouverneur c'est
[Musique]
non mais nous ne savons pas exactement
mais ce que nous savons que ça ça vient
du service des domaines
le service des domaines des arts
distribuer les terrains euros mais tu es
mon bébé sans le consulter
nous allons vers une lettre à vous
servir le domaine et aussi pro
gouvernement à toutes les instances
supérieures même aux gouvernements d'âge
[Musique]
difficile de parier sur mer ont été
assez difficiles
voilà parce que à feintool où tout
autant celui mois tout en serait point
de vue des problèmes de la vie quoi même
s'il ya des problèmes de la famille
là-bas c'est le bel qui sont asus il
consulte joue la belle prend du poids
même de ceux qui se battent même le
moyen de le problème de terrain
un seul
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ayez mois de la fnh économie maritime
des invertis caractère d'être médecin ne
tente pas retenir les profonds mallet
voulant jouer
mazars décentralisation j'étais
renfermant des oiseaux surtout ma forme
est un ami et sédhiou des oiseaux
informations votre arafat at il osé
l'arrivée lycée le dd d'en boire kizuna
taua puis en commission a mené par
pendaison en asie à tony commis car est
ambitieux formation et allemagne les
fonds doivent souvent les délibérations
manière et où il s'est dit mais bien car
autrement dit la petite amie et ils
n'ont pas arrêté découpant youtube en
tant que base habitat faune aquatique et
bazars découpage 5 millions d'emplois en
cinq lignes ont besoin d'un spa 5
millions tribune les frondeurs 10
millions antennes paraboliques 50
millions pour sa voix s'élèvent à 70
millions ballon labourie 7 millions
terres et 10 cas finira tôt 5000 au
filet en a fourni par les acteurs
christian 44 millions entre apparentés
aux voitures assemblées nationales et
radio fm 11 millions nestor président en
tant qu'ong lambic 50 millions que des
travaux sur yonne
les andalous ont défendu m un mignon
puisqu'il est un talent d'alain millions
dé litres galles 25 millions pour les
cimes en 35 min axée sur la promotion
des 11000 aux îles et aux hommes et
qu'elle a enfin les automatiques m56 des
isles en voyageant au final
mino milani zoo et communiquent biseau
et tombe à l'eau l'art 12,7 minots de la
police ibrahim
cette vidéo et vous trouvez le temps de
retrouver trois tireurs simply nationale
ou dans banca di roma au niveau de notre
temps dans un bâton si l'assemblée
nationale 44 millions des séminaires
pour la toise à 44 millions us de
l'amour les varois a des inconvénients
mme marois garçons comme il ya huit ans
à la défense bacary nous avons communié
avoir dans les news
si la vita voyait de coûts minimums sais
ce que je vaux d'un loser président
sortant est aussi doué comité local de
sécurité rennaise touché une version
fournie apparemment jeu en berne notable
là je vous rends en avoir analysé les
communications radio à château
communication tv je crois que nos amis
peut faire l'enregistrement pour la
petite communication
mais ça c'est le calme dans les alizés à
ce taux est à présent une solution
acheter des bateaux dans l'immédiat dans
l'immédiat les civils
20 millions de roupies 10 millions sans
ce t3 maison des aînés store très
amusant technologiques ces cantines
hop
[Musique]
son ami cependant pas celle des médias
pour guérir femmes sont mignons sa
droite pour mai qui talonnait si j
allais le cfd a gaspillé au total 477
millions de francs malgache l'équivalent
du budget de la mairie de morombe solo
on aurait certainement fait un meilleur
usage
[Musique]
je m'arrête ouais
enfin les patients
c'est par les choses parce que là des
matières de la vie d'amy adams balles
lors vous devez rame sur deux
c'est pas juste bien sûr
bah
amer pour les clés
la distribution d'eau les a quand même
retrouvé un financement
m'expliquer ce que c'est son financement
un financement de la banque mondiale
toujours et comment tu trouves un
financement
c'était un tunnel c'était une
il faut que le jean papeau verts s'ils
acceptent n'accepte que je ramène à
tuner négociable ceux de la barre
mondiale parce que si nous mêmes nous
n'avons pas la trezia de la distribution
d'électricité les hommes et des raisons
pas assez il faut que nous ayons des
bornes fontaines dans tous les quartiers
il ya certes un certain secteur qui n'en
n'ont pas
il fait
ok les choses sont réglées
aïe
[Musique]
pourtant
vous commencez au sujet nous avons 104
élèves parmi ces 104 élèves il y à 68
élèves en 6e 5e et 4e
c'est la fin de l'année et madame baban
directrice du collège remède prix offert
par la mairie aux meilleurs élèves c'est
aussi la dernière année dans ce collège
car la rentrée prochaine est prévue dans
un nouvel établissement plus grand et
mieux équipée puisqu'il pourra
accueillir 200 élèves
peut-être un début pour améliorer le
taux d'alphabétisation à bombay 50% des
femmes et 45 % des hommes sont
analphabètes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le mans mène à l'entrée de la ville sur
le site du nouveau collège où il a
rendez vous avec le fournisseur de
matériaux le chef de chantier
il a été alerté par narcisse de rumeurs
de réutilisation de tout âge et pour
couvrir le collège à la place des tôles
neuves prévu dans le contrat
ap ap
pas simple
la plaque
or voilà servi
à noter un polygame à des problèmes
techniques prévues à leur récupération
sur un tel bâtiment des fines
rapatriement des choses sont allées
beaucoup les positions des lasagnes
objectif final là que ce soit fait
enfin tout moi l'objectif
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'ai entendu un truc sur les parents
devaient aussi payer une partie
contribuer un peu là où elle et par an
contre les billets 5000 francs par parra
et puisque senna n'est que le début
il faut que les parents participent en
principe à ce que la population doit
parti doit participer mais de celle on a
encore un problème pour toute la
population était ricco sella rugby qui
l'avait que deux bailleurs la banque
mondiale la banque mondiale le monde aux
gens me conclu
ouais et sans la contribution des ans
jusqu'à concurrence de 20 % le
financement n'est pas débloquée
moi personnellement je trouve que c'est
quand même normal puisque si des choses
ont été donnés gratuitement
on n'a pas sonné sans paillettes
responsable moi je suis d'accord avec la
participation mais 20% à me paraît un
peu élevé l'accord pour combien moi je
pense à 10% ça va ça c'est le bailleul
d'ailleurs les bailleurs locale on me
voit bien les élèves issus comment bien
sûr mais en plus il a déjà le
financement des montpellier on va s'en
est tous les boucliers la place je suis
là sans leur en reste peu ou var et de
l'électricité de l'eau il n'y a pas de
crise qu'ils n'ont alors qu'à n la bonne
équipe et un labo de l la peau de chimie
physique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quant au sénateur lui il m'a dit qu'il
allait vous aider pour lutter contre la
fraude fiscale
qu'est ce qu'on va faire il peut
utiliser toute la puissance publique
peut le faire un que ça peut m'aider
dans le coup vraiment 10
il ya un vrai problème bien sûr puisque
j'ai fait un bilan de les couvrir mois
où les étés à ces deux poussant un petit
problème de civisme et donc
faut les deux éduquer les ans et petit
prix somme toute la puissance publique
la petite pression par en haut c'est aux
sénateurs questeur que le maire fait
référence car en effet lui seul peut lui
apporter le soutien de la police pour
verbaliser les contrevenants
aucun gros lot mais maintenant nous
après midi notre jeu des missions sabata
effet relève a tout capté in amenas de
cordes d'une guitare cas ce qu'a dit
fier ni commune farman à la can à 15
heures cet handicap d'annaba où beaucoup
disent aux matous arena pétanque et à
thann en commune i did you think flat
hat et ran qui étaient ses fans antifi
réveil 8 et u démarche alan dit
nani est un état total zanias là il doit
passer deux années
nadeo tout citoyen qui est un membre a
fait ça n'a pas que ce professionnel
si je suis ici j'ai voulu comprendre
pourquoi madagascar par est incapable à
se développer
j'ai appris qu'il suffit de laisser
mourir une route et de détourner
insidieusement l'argent public pour
étouffer une ville comme le pays
bombay a un réel potentiel qu'il serait
dommage de laisser partir en fumée
conséquence de cette absurdité 75 % de
la population vit toujours en deçà du
seuil de pauvreté
[Applaudissements]
pour ce lot la route est encore longue
mais il sait qu'il roule dans le bon
sens
[Musique]